it's totally opaque we don't know how
the process really is being determined
and who gets sort of marked for death hi
I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and today
we're talking with Eli Lake who's the
senior national security correspondent
for The Daily Beast a Newsweek Eli
thanks for talking to us thanks for
having me Nick one of the big stories
coming out is President Obama's ability
or the list that he's generated of
likely terrorist suspects that he says
he has the right to kill this is
something that you talked about years
ago and you talked about more broadly
about how Obama seem to be continuing or
even expanding some of the most
controversial aspects of the bush
security state where are we are you
surprised by the Obama list and the way
that it's being discussed to it to a
degree we could have presumed something
like this was happening it's totally
opaque we don't know how the process
really is being determined and who gets
sort of marked for death we also don't
know how many jurists are involved in
this process of any and by that if
there's any kind of judicial oversight
or check I mean we don't even know if
other you know if the government the
government wants two suspects an
American of being foreign intelligence
agent it needs to go to a court secret
court to get a warrant to tap their
phones and read their email and do other
things like that was a FISA Court if
someone is suspected being a member of
al-qaeda there's no court that we know
of where the president can go to sort of
do it now there is an expansive
definition of wartime authorities for
the executive that I guess John you and
dick cheney and Dave Anton would say are
would include this power to go after
even american citizens-- have they
stepped up I mean have people like John
you and dick cheney and the architects
of the bush Security Response have they
said yet what Obama's doing well totally
in 2009 Dick Cheney did criticize Obama
for sort of considering the prosecution
or reopening certain kinds of cases
against CIA officers does there need to
be an explicit understanding or a new
protocol set up that is transparent and
and if not transparent at least able to
be checked so that we were not in a
position where we're just trusting our
government to do the right thing I mean
it's interesting that you you put that
that way I think that there should be
some process like a FISA Court that
works at least for US citizens who are
going to be killed in these drone
programs and drone strikes I think
overall the development of drones or
UAVs or against unmanned aerial vehicles
or whatever our is you know it
represents an advance and that these
tend to be more precise even though
sometimes they get the wrong targets
then certainly airpower used in the
Vietnam War and certainly airpower used
in World War two so overall and you
could point to a kind of a more humane
trendline are we at a moment in time
where defense spending and military
spending is going to come down it's less
I think the overall number but what kind
of military did we want the military to
be and I would just say that the cheaper
counterterrorism military of having the
ability to conduct drone strikes all
over the world you know and sort of a
strategy which is sometimes crudely
called mowing the grass is I mean is
that something that we want forever is
that I mean and then then it leads you
to because certainly what we're not
going to see is David General David
Petraeus and his he's not going to have
his coin his counter insurgency army
where the military where these like kind
of was not just a military that fought
wars they were building nations as well
and but the advantage of a coin military
is that at some point at some end date
the ghost country is competent enough
and professional enough that you don't
need to have a drone base there in order
to get the bad girl that they can handle
it there and they can handle them
digitally that's at least the end goal
and so I think that you're going to be
caught between those two things and
obvious
the coin military is more expensive than
the sort of counterterrorism military
with drones and then a cyber element and
things like that what needs to happen to
have a kind of mum of where there is a
broad-based consensus well I think there
is a bit a beginning of a policy
consensus emerging it's okay to send
UAVs and special forces into weak states
for targeted pinpoint missions meant to
kill or capture terrorist leaders or
something like that the question is
who's going to pick up the slack and do
the harder job of training up you know
the Yemeni counterterrorism Coast Guard
unit because that's a hard job thankless
it's expensive it's dangerous who's
responsible for that they used to be
America and do you think that there will
be a consensus about what are the limits
on the stealth of military intervention
or of security aspects of you know
things like enemies less or who's
generating the list though well I think
there's much better chance if
libertarians are worried about it of
introducing some sort of oversight and
what's the word I'm looking for like if
you have oversight and also a process
that's sort as transparent as it can be
oversight in some degree of transparency
in that process than it is to sort of
say we can't do it or take the argument
that you may have heard before nine
eleven which is that we have no right to
send a drone into Yemen or something
like that and then I think the other
thing I would just say is that the
consensus that sort of emerged is will
shatter or will be reformed or will
change if there is a horrific terrorist
attack the United States well we're
going to leave it there Thank You Eli
Lake of Newsweek and The Daily Beast for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you